pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
mercredi dernier vous avez partagé
l'émotion des élèves et des professeurs
du lycée Saint Thomas d'Aquin de
Saint-Jean-de-Luz je vous en remercie ce
drame absolu n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec la violence qui gangrène nos
collègues et nos lycée où la difficile
détection des situations de détresse des
adolescents de ces sujets nous
reparlerons quand l'émotion sera passée
pour l'heure je voudrais vous narrer
l'histoire d'un inspecteur d'académie
venu dans un petit village de France
calculer le nombre d'élèves attendus
pour la prochaine rentrée par la fenêtre
de l'école plusieurs maisons en
construction devant accueillir dans deux
ou trois ans des familles avec enfants
mais ce qui se passera dans deux trois
ans n'intéresse pas Monsieur
l'Inspecteur d'Académie l'école à la
prochaine rentrée perdra trois élèves
trois élèves en moins un professeur en
moins une classe qui ferme tel est le
verdict ce rituel immuable qui sent bon
la Quatrième République la carte
scolaire rituel qui conduit chaque année
les espèces ont académie de France et de
Navarre à sortir le règle à calcul pour
compter les élèves et décider du sort
des postes et des classes et pendant ce
temps l'état demande aux élus d'escrire
leur politique d'urbanisme dans
l'estradettes Scott peluy ou plu
imposant au maire de voir loin monsieur
le ministre jusqu'à quand resterez-vous
le seul de vos collègues qui adaptent
chaque année les postes au comptage à
l'unité près de ces usagers monsieur le
ministre accueille une procédure
pluriannuelle de la carte scolaire
adaptée à notre époque bref monsieur le
ministre au ministère d'éducation
nationale l'entrée dans la modernité
c'est pour quand
pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
Monsieur papendaï Merci Merci monsieur
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Max
Brisson je m'associe bien sûr l'hommage
que vous venez de rendre à Agnès LaSalle
assassiné dans l'exercice de ses
fonctions elle consacrait sa vie à ses
élèves et mes pensées vont à sa famille
à ses collègues et à ses élèves tout
atteinte contre un professeur porte
atteinte à la République c'est ce que
j'ai dit sur place avec Stanislas
Guérini le ministre de la Fonction
publique avec vous-même avec la
sénatrice espagnole et avec le maire de
Saint-Jean-de-Luz Jean-François Irigoyen
à propos de votre question la carte
scolaire tient compte bien sûr d'une
manière générale de la baisse des
effectifs scolaires qui sera j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire dans cette
hémicycle très importantes l'année
prochaine ce qui nous amène à fermer des
classes ici à en ouvrir là dans votre
département des Pyrénées-Atlantiques
nous comptons environ 450 élèves de
moins l'année prochaine tout en veillant
à ce que le taux d'encadrement
particulièrement dans les régions
rurales continuent de s'améliorer ce qui
sera en effet le cas dans votre
département des ajustements d'ici au
mois de juin vont avoir lieu en
particulier sur quelques points
sensibles
éventuellement ceux que vous connaissez
tout en donnant priorité au RPI les
regroupements pédagogiques
intercommunaux donc aux zones rurales à
propos de pluriannuel nous avons un
regard pluriannuel sur les évolutions
démographiques qui nous est fournie par
les statistiques du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale ainsi que par les
rectorats mais il faut aussi tenir
compte des variations annuelles des
migrations des familles qui s'installent
des déménagements ce qui oblige
effectivement à construire annuellement
une carte scolaire mais nous proclame
encore au stade des ajustements je vous
remercie monsieur Brisson
je ne vous ai pas parlé depuis
latentiques je vous ai parlé de
procédures de la carte scolaire je crois
qu'il est grand temps que l'on travaille
avec les acheteurs d'élus pour entrer
dans une démarche plus réelle les merles
peuvent plus d'avoir un comptable chaque
année dans leurs écoles qui viennent
calculer le nombre d'élèves alors qu'ils
savent comme lotissement est en cours de
préparation et que dans un an dans deux
ans il y aura à nouveau des enfants
c'est cette vision comptable qu'on vous
demande d'abandonner pour une démarche
plus réelle